welcome back to on base live I'm your
and you're live in your Bleacher Report
app I'm your host Mookie Betts and today
we got Sid Mullins my boy said buns how
you doing brother I'm doing all right
man you know it's an honor to be here
talking to you just chilling all right
my brother so
um
thank you for joining first
[Music]
um I want to give a couple accolades
2021 Silver Slugger and you're an
All-Star that year
how and you're the first Oriole to join
the 30 30 Club yes so tell me about that
because you know I have my experience
and
I feel like when I joined that club
it was that's super dope that means you
was balling there I was bawling at you
yeah and I want to hear like from your
experience
That season how you you saw not the
season but just the 30 30 part the home
runs and the bases I know because you
know you know it's coming you know it's
coming up and you saw the last 27-28
homers 27 28 bags where you like oh I'm
right there like what was that like
motivation for you nah for sure uh
coming up on the stolen basis I'm trying
to think I for sure got the basis first
sure got the bases first and even that
was like a grind yeah towards the end of
the season then coming up on eating that
last home run with about two weeks left
I felt all the pressure that yeah I was
trying I I was flying out so much it was
ridiculous uh you know it was literally
right around the time okay we had played
we were playing Texas it was about
seven days left in the season Texas came
into town
and they had alrighty starters and I was
like skip I need to be in there every
day I gotta get this last home run and
as soon as I tried to hit a blind drive
over short
that's how it always happens man you're
not even trying us I'm talking about a
home run derby so before we get into it
man I know you were here you missed the
last couple of days you good what's
cracking everything good yeah it's a
little tweak you know I had the uh the
groin injury earlier in the year uh
missed about 20 games or so
it's uh it might be related but it's
right on the quad now I was able to stop
it from being something serious just day
to day nice I wonder how like because I
feel like here man it's so hot is it
hard to like stay hydrated because
yesterday we was in New York and I mean
golly you just walk outside you just
start sweating yeah the humidity is
crazy yeah so you got to drink a lot
drink a lot of fluids yeah you gotta you
gotta stay hydrated it's tough to kind
of do everything yeah like stay hydrated
eat right you know it's
we do hydration tests you know just to
make sure that everyone's good that day
and if not get the chugging yeah
something that you just try to keep keep
the body going but uh yeah this is what
it is uh so I got a game on base off
base
you and you're out that's what it is so
all right on base off base Lamar Jackson
will be the next MVP in Baltimore
I'm in on that you're in on that yeah
you like Lamar I like Lamar yeah are you
you're a football fan so I watch
football just kind of on the whim you
know just uh I don't pay too much
attention up until playoffs yeah okay
just because you know season
shoot uh most cases we just wrapping up
ours trying to get back home settle in
you play Fantasy I do play Fantasy yeah
I'm terrible at it terrible okay so
don't be note to self don't ever
play with my boy said what about this
um cooking meals on the road you on base
or off base cooking meals on the road
for myself for yourself oh for your
teammates whoever you want yeah they'll
be all right
okay Dad I'm I'm beginning on that on
this
Uber Uber Eats all the time it's old and
very expensive so you say you're a chef
like you you enjoy cooking
yeah I enjoy cooking I'm not a Master
Chef or anything but but you enjoy yeah
I enjoy cooking on the occasion well I'm
gonna let you know now there's a product
coming out
and I don't know when okay but it's
gonna be a uh
it's not a briefcase it's like a little
suitcase type situation with
it's a suitcase kitchen that's what it
is it's gonna be a suitcase kitchen okay
and um
I want you to buy one you want me to buy
one I want you to buy one since you're
you're a chef what comes with it
um so can we run the tape please my
suitcase kitchen okay you know this is
mine that's why you're a person saying
okay okay so I got my pots and my pants
actually upstairs and my pots in my pans
I got the burners I got the seasonings
you know I got the jellies the peanut
butter okay anything and everything so
if you hungry tonight you know after the
game
[Music]
so okay what about this North Carolina
has the best barbecue on base or off
base
I'm from North Carolina I know oh man
North Carolina and Georgia Nick I know I
know uh well
I got to go just to save face I know I
know Grandma gonna see this at some
point so I got to be on that I guess
okay all right shout out to Grandma
how's her barbecue by the way
I don't know she doesn't really
but yeah she put a foot in there yes
her best dish potato salad yeah okay
oh it got some kick to it too that most
of them don't it's it's next level next
time Grandma's here can you make sure
you uh oh yeah I know the recipe oh okay
whip that up yeah okay all right so what
about Naruto is the best anime
on base or off base uh uh yeah no I'd
say it's song based for sure um so I I
got a genuine question
and it's and it's and this is from my
heart okay
what is anime because to me all I know
is it just looks like cartoons
and I don't want to just to a degree
it's it's cartoons with a story so if
you yeah but SpongeBob got a story too
no I don't
yeah he starts somewhere and they got to
solve the problem you gotta but there's
no storyline that's just a story each
time
so anime is like a whole it's like
watching
um Game of Thrones if it was a cartoon
[Music]
um
that's what it is to me
that's what anime so that's that's it
okay so the only difference is it's got
a storyline from episode one to episode
10. yeah SpongeBob got a storyline for
minute one to minute eleven there you go
that's it okay yeah all right so let's
switch back to Bass box I know you know
I know you're a big anime guy but I mean
I I don't want to get your juices going
too much you know what I'm saying so
let's switch back to baseball you guys
are balling this year
y'all cool if the season ended today
y'all would be in playoffs and
I was I played against Baltimore for a
while I was there when Manny and uh Adam
Jones and Mark Trumbo all those guys
Chris Davis all those guys there
really they're on top of the world
making playoffs yes and then went
through a little drought and the drought
is kind of when you came up yeah and so
you've seen both sides how is that like
what you know how that was that was a
crazy time because you're trying to
solidify solidify yourself in the big
leagues
you're trying to win
and it's tough you know it's it's one of
those moments where
you're trying to be a team player and
put your numbers up at the same time I
think that gets missed yeah that gets
missed you know because even on a good
team though even on a good team you're
you want to do the same thing yeah but
it's harder on a you know when your
team's is not as good right yeah so um
you know because you
you want to get paid everybody does yeah
you know and you got to put up your
numbers to do that but you also gotta
want to win the game and play the game
and those type of things and so what was
it that what was it that you had to
focus on in order to kind of achieve
both
um just really dialing in on what kind
of player I was on on the field just uh
you know this was I the guy to
continuously you know move guys over
when needed uh was I the guy to try to
try to make stuff something happen every
single time I came up to the plate you
know so kind of finding that balance of
hey this is someone where you need to be
you know the the guy to move them over
potentially get a base hit or hey this
is the guy this is the moment where
swing for the fence like we need some
pop out of you but why is it important
for you to know what kind of player you
are
it keeps a lot of
noise out of your head because for sure
you're gonna have a lot of people that
have an idea of what you should be as a
player and
if you've been playing for so long at
some point you have an idea of who you
are
just a matter of being consistent in the
big leagues and I I feel like I'm kind
of going through that now and this is
almost my 10th year like I started off
and I was the guy to kind of you know
bun a guy over move a little you know
move guys over and then you know kind of
three four five years into into it it
was like guys second you know they still
want you to drive they still want to do
driving yeah and so and now it's like I
don't know where I'm hitting like home
run I don't know where it's coming from
but and I'm enjoying it but you know
it's almost like a new profile that I
have and so I'm kind of lost myself like
I don't even know who I am this is this
is weird you know and so uh but it's fun
it is what it is so and now you're
you're not necessarily the young guy but
you're not the old guy either yeah and
the game has changed is changing so much
and you got a lot of young guys coming
up
um
you got a young guy pitching for you
guys tonight you got Ava you got Gunner
what's it like having those guys
be a part of a a success story like this
because usually in baseball you need
some vets some vets are are they they
help the team a lot yeah but now it's
kind of like you need some young guys
yeah we still have those guys that you
know have that veteran presence even if
uh they're coming from you know other
teams other backgrounds in terms of
their careers uh but yeah I think the uh
the culture that
me Austin Hayes Anthony Santander like
guys like us that have kind of created
in the clubhouse makes it comfortable
for both sides both veterans and young
guys coming in so
yeah just making them comfortable making
them understand that hey like at the end
of the day we go out there we we play
our best we we you know put our work in
beforehand we prepare every single day
for the win and I feel like the the
common thing I've seen there is you
Santander Austin Hayes you guys all came
up
when the team wasn't that good yeah and
so now
I feel like you guys have you know what
you want you know what it takes and it's
easier to show the young guys because
now we're winning yeah and we're the
guys in charge yeah it's uh like for
sure all three of us had crazy ups and
downs injuries here or there
again just that learning curve right
what does it take to get through a full
season and what does it take to get
through a full season successfully
yeah and so you you
I want to talk about adley for a quick
second because I gave him his flowers uh
for what he did in the derby yes
that was dope that was sick right and so
to him
you were a switch hitter tell me about
that because when you first came up I
remember seeing Cedric Mullins and I'm
like this this little dude up here he's
switching like you know he was slapping
stuff around you wasn't driving it like
you are now and so trying to tell me how
you're that because I was part of part
of a profile change for you yeah uh for
sure you know to I guess to start with
uh adley like to for him to have as much
success he did switch hitting like all
throughout the levels it just made sense
for him to continue that and even though
he kind of struggled on his right side
early when he first came up probably
facing that many lefties but to come
back and make the adjustments he did and
flourishing with him that's what I
expected to see from him terms of me as
a switch hitter the numbers never really
matched up
each year to the success I was having my
left side was carrying it every single
time so when it finally came to the bigs
that's when it got isolated and
I would have a bunch of moments where
I'd be hitting left-handed big moment
would come up
the left-handed arm would come out to
put you to put me on the right side and
I had so much failure coming with that
that it just got to the point where a
change needed to be made for
basically my career and for me to say
worst case scenario I'm just as bad left
on left just made sense
and so how long did it take you
to start facing lefties for you to get
comfortable because you I mean you
switch it you switch into the business
that means you you never really faced
you never really went left and left yeah
no so I didn't I didn't go left on left
until the big so that let's see going
into the 2020 off season going in 2021.
I had just hit left on left the entire
time didn't face a single right-handed
picture so where like on just like like
yeah or like live BPS
against uh some high school guys oh nice
okay 586 something I can kind of see
easily uh for the most part you know see
some spin yeah you know guys like
through strikes yeah for sure take my
head off every single time I came up
it's only 85. yeah still got no idea 85
I heard but uh but yeah you know a lot
of machine machine work you know drastic
angles but they're way behind me just to
get comfortable with an arm slot that
might come behind me right like a Chris
Sale type person
and at that point it was just uh coming
in getting as many reps as possible
showing I could do it and was able to do
that so when you when you told did you
tell the team that you're gonna do this
or did they tell you yeah so we had had
some communication about it
um
even when the new regime came in in 2019
so it was just kind of those will
monitor you know kind of what goes on
and uh when I had uh officially said how
I want to make the switch they were
full support of it you know so they
wanted to show you but they they didn't
know how to it was uh
I think they were just comfortable with
whatever I was comfortable with okay so
it was uh
just one of those things where you know
again playing on a team that wasn't
playing well just trying to find ways to
have success individually and as a team
that was the way to do it so were you
nervous when you
nervous anxious whatever word when you
first got you know when you first your
first couple of bats against lefties and
everybody's watching like Okay so let's
see what he's gonna do you know what I'm
saying it was a nothing to lose moment
okay so you just you looked at it from
that point I just kind of had that
thought on it and you know put all the
guards on just to protect myself and my
thoughts but uh the first the first
picture I faced uh during spring
training was uh Montgomery Jordan
Montgomery George Montgomery so
obviously has some good stuff and I hit
a ball off the wall for a triple I was
like you know it's spring training so
but at the same time like okay this is a
quick start so just finding some early
success and uh that's kind of helped
them that definitely helped it and just
kind of carried that on literally
through Offspring training all through
the season and you know
the guy started making adjustments but
that was just yeah that's the part of
that point yeah that's probably going
back and forth so so
I I like I said I was in Boston for six
years came up
seen the ups and downs but I think what
gets missed a lot is even though
Baltimore was maybe not that good
at the time the AL East is also that
tough
yes being that playing there and now
playing in the west and this there's no
shot no shade at the West at all because
there are some now we got some really
good teams but when I first got to the
West
it didn't compare to these to the AL
East
and it's just every team in the East was
just stacked yeah there was no
rebuilding no there's you know
everybody was just cold yeah and I want
to hear your experience of it because I
you know I've been out for the last four
or five years so you know what's changed
I know a lot of there's a lot of new
faces in the East that I haven't seen
yeah
um like you said like coming into the
league being in the AL East
was really unfamiliar with the division
like I grew up a Braves fan always knew
about you know at least that's all I
knew and when I started playing these
teams
I was like yo we play these guys 20
times each
we just gonna be beating up on each
other and if you just didn't have it
you will go and get smacked yes it is it
is like that every night every time yeah
it was unbelievable and so now but and
now it's it's
even like it's really even like anybody
can win the East now so that's that's
all y'all are got 50 wins like all y'all
are if you put yourself in another
position or another division
you're kind of you're in first or second
you know I'm saying close to First and
yeah so that just that's tough and the
arms you're facing every day yeah just
uh just the whole
just everything about it yeah it just
felt like dude the AL East the arms are
different it's nasty hey at least the
hitters are different yeah yeah
everything every time we face each other
I feel like the game is just different
yeah you just feel that intensity yeah
when we Face these teams and it's just
uh but it's fun it's fun at the same
time when you come out with the win or
the series especially because you know
you know you earned it yeah you know for
sure there's no fluke so
also in the AL East there's a lot of
history
with the parks Camden Yards
Fenway Yankees Yankee Stadium
um
what's this new the new Left Field and
everything because I haven't been here
since you know since this is has it has
it messed with the history of it like is
there can you feel like a new tradition
starting I know you got the water in
left field and all those type of things
like yeah did that add or take away a
little bit from the history it it uh I'd
say it's gonna add to it because it's it
just feels like the the culture of
Baltimore especially at Camden Yards is
continuously changing at the uh got the
Mr Splash out there making Water Works
yeah the fans and you know uh more
interaction with the fans is always good
I've always thought that and uh but yeah
once you see that wall
you don't want to go opposite field it's
that big man it's unbelievable I as a
left-handed hitter
I don't think like you can think of the
strongest Lefty you know they're not
going it's not going out over there
they're not going out there it's too far
it's just and the wall is huge and it's
really high you're not robbing nothing
you're gonna have to wait for it to come
now all right so tell me what your
favorite stadium is what's your favorite
Stadium favorite state have you been to
all the stadiums I've not been to all
the stadiums okay so out of the ones
that you've been to yeah
uh
there's a couple
just one just one I'm driving and just
trying to break it up I'll give you mine
right now mine mine is Kansas City and
you can argue that oh that's because you
bang when you go there yeah that's a
great that that does play A Part yeah
but just the the look of Kansas City the
backdrop the waterfall they got the uh
Museum in left field the food is good
the parking everything I just enjoy it
all yeah you know the club I like the
clubhouse
the the guys in there are awesome so
that's kind of what played a part in
Kansas city is is and this is there's a
lot of great guys in every every
ballpark right yeah but it's just
everything about Kansas I don't know I
just love it so I'd say mine this one's
probably a shock Minnesota is really
nice Minnesota's dope Minnesota is
really nice it is like the so what but
why Minnesota like what they they do
have a view you know definitely got the
view but I feel like the stadium goes
like just up you just kind of feel like
closed a little bit and it just it's a
comfortable feeling and then when you go
out into the city the food is good like
you said the club is all those guys are
great take care of you real real good
they're awesome and uh
no traffic never
no no traffic as far as I can tell yeah
it's it's really nice out there okay so
I'm gonna ask this but and I'm expecting
one answer okay but we'll see
what's your least favorite
yeah all around
Boston be killing me Boston what
I thought for sure a lot of success I
thought for sure you would say Oakland
we don't go there as much okay that's so
that's why it's like ah I'll I'll handle
it okay but Oakland's obviously like
Oakland is is the worst but Boston now
you got to learn me about wow you don't
like Boston okay well uh because this is
this is that's that's taking that's
stabbed me right there
I hit my first home run there just last
year
[Laughter]
so the first one at that Stadium that's
all the times I've been there it's a big
part
the away Clubhouse is very tight okay
I've never been very tight on the
Wayside it's I I don't know how old the
lockers are there
couldn't place a date on them really
they are
like slamming right next to each other
you're stacked that's the history though
100 so you understand yeah so so
remember the uh so the kova season they
separated everybody we were outside of
the original Clubhouse and we had way
more room then
okay so and it was in 30 degree weather
they have a really changed but you can't
though it's Fenway there's nowhere to
move but you know there and and that's
why that's why there's nothing that
could change that's what it is so that's
that's fine so bought and then you know
there's a little traffic in there I mean
horrible traffic but yeah you could walk
from the hotel I don't even know
anything about it I've never been hotels
amazing okay so I'll I'll know in August
we'll see all right so I want to know
some more about said right so
let's go with your journey back um in
high school right you didn't play ball
until really your junior senior year or
so I wasn't a starter you wouldn't have
started okay you played but you didn't
start until your junior senior year
which is late yeah because for most of
us you know we started our freshman year
and then you go all the way through
right yeah so uh yeah yeah tell me about
that like you didn't really start until
your junior senior year was there some
good guys in front of you what was yeah
I could I could clear it up so I was a
starter for the freshman team for the JV
team okay so that was first two years
when it came to Varsity during your
sophomore junior year I didn't start on
varsity so sophomore year
they actually asked me to try out for
the varsity team
but if you were already on the freshman
and JV team you had to try it again I
still I didn't it was weird because I
was
I was a sophomore basically knew I was
going to be on the JV team but they said
hey we want you to try for Varsity okay
okay
go out there felt like I showed out I
got cut but then I asked well do I still
have to try out for JV like oh you got
cut from The Voice from the varsity team
that year
and then was on JV but then I was still
playing with varsity
that year what kind of school you go to
what what what was uh what is what that
didn't even make sense to me so
Brookwood High School it was like a 5A
6A school so like top tier in terms of
public schools
so they had this this is this sounds
weird to me so if you were it was not on
the varsity team
and if you were on the JV team that does
not meet like you're not it doesn't flow
to the vars like you got to try it again
to get technically you do try out
every single year you do try out every
single year for the team because you got
new guys coming in yeah I guess you know
it's a big school district we had 4 000
kids going to that school okay
throughout all the grades so it's like
you never knew so once you got your
opportunity though you ran with it so
tell me when you got the opportunity
what was your mind like what were you
thinking about yeah so uh junior year I
had uh there's a there's a sitter filter
Trey Martin he was uh got drafted by the
Cubs okay I was like yeah that ain't no
problem man you know a couple other guys
went to some uh some kind of just played
baseball following up uh high school you
know obviously I felt like I could play
mix in
didn't work out that way so I was just
locked in on what I could control which
was you know just being ready
um
hitting up schools you know trying to
find colleges that will have some
interest uh planning my summer going
into my senior year seeing what uh what
could line up with that because I had
some schools interested and
literally going to junior year the first
day that they could talk to you
I had like three phone calls that day I
was like okay you know still have a ton
of interest and literally by the time I
wasn't starting on the varsity team all
those schools disappeared of course
okay all right well back to square one
and my dad
credit to him but he put me through it
he printed out every single school that
had a baseball program
he said I want you to go through it
that's a long long list I'm talking
about 50 pages long of just lines he
said I want you to go through it pick
out schools that you have interest in
send them an email
I don't know how many emails I sent
how long did it take you to do that
oh a few weeks what
so if you sent the email sent the emails
and would get some response back
kind of go through the processes
and none of them were really taken but
then senior year when I finally was
starting we played a tournament in Cary
North Carolina
and a junior college was out there
watching Lewisburg College they had a
scout out there
said we like you
um so what would you say then when he
said we like you like what it inside
said inside was saying finally okay like
somebody it doesn't have to be the huge
D1 I said somebody I just said at this
point I was looking to
just continue baseball okay I was like
this is uh that's like you so you did
want to play you had like dreams and you
wanted to play the next level where I'm
at right now was the dream okay where
you're at right now was it a bit of the
big leagues so that was a dream and
going that hearing Lewisburg say we like
you
you felt like oh I I now I have this is
my next step to the big leagues yes so
you go to go to Louisburg or Lewis okay
so how was Lewisburg Louisburg was a
campus of it was a private Junior
College
campus about 800 folks so very small
uh kind of felt like at HBCU there oh
nice okay don't buy folks you know just
try to make better themselves okay and I
put up numbers bald pulled up put up
some numbers and
kind of transitioning put my two years
in
just looking at the drive your draft
eligible each year out of your college
so still that being the goal I was like
I'm perfectly fine with golden Junior
College I can get drafted freshman year
sophomore year or transfer and go from
there and that's basically what happened
transferred to Campbell University so
did Campbell so tell me about that in
between so you were balling at Lewisburg
yep and then Campbell called you did
they call the coach so how was it do
they call Pops no kind of the same
process as Louisburg we played a
tournament as Junior College they had a
Campbell hosted a junior college
tournament oh okay okay their facility
okay and that's when they saw me there
and that's when the conversation started
they showed a ton of interest
um in fact got offered a full ride oh
nice okay to go somewhere where I know
I'm gonna play you know save my parents
that's the most important thing yeah I
said that's kind of an easy decision
and then there were there were Scouts
that were coming through Campbell that's
you know kind of getting the whole
layout of what I was going to be going
into
and that's exactly what happened you
know went transferred there knew I was
gonna get some looks all I had to do was
perform one year or two year camera two
years ago one year at Campbell one year
at Camp so two at Lewisburg one at
Campbell then you got drafted in the
15th 13th 13th 13 13 15. 13th round
2015. when you got drafted
13th round because that's late really
yeah that's day three that that's that's
day three like typically
day three guys for the most part
statistically don't make it yeah right
and so for you you're like you know this
is a great opportunity what what was it
for you because you there's no way you
could matter you could care that you got
drafted in 13th round because it's your
opportunity yeah it didn't didn't care
um
Planet playing at Louisburg playing at
Campbell there was a
uh Oriole Scout Rich Morales who
followed me kind of throughout that
whole process and Did You Know Rich the
whole time or did you I got introduced
to him my sophomore year at Lewisburg
okay all right so he did say basically I
need to see one more year out of you at
a more competitive level
okay okay that sounds good so then you
go to Campbell then so okay you got
drafted
yeah just kind of thinking about
like you said the opportunity the the
round didn't matter I honestly felt like
as long as my name was called everyone
was on the same playing field right like
you have to show your worth and that's
that's a fact the only real difference
is when you get drafted late your leash
is just shorter that's yeah that's
really the only the only the first first
round guy is gonna get
five chances we're the 13th round guy
maybe only get one yeah which I knew and
it was pretty obvious and pretty evident
when I got drafted with a bunch of guys
that were later rounds as well and you
just
saw that they were just getting chopped
left and right and I was like my draft
class is shrinking right yeah crazy fast
after one or two years like you walk you
look around like you don't know anybody
everyone's coming in the draft after me
and the guys that you know were first
rounders were obviously going to be
around but I was looking around and I
was like I'm kind of the last one that's
even past the 10th yeah around at this
point and so and so
going through the minor leagues
how was it for you because you know
everybody everyone knows like you know
where you everyone knows where everyone
got drafted so like it's kind of I'm not
it's not really like a pecking order but
you kind of know who has more chances
and who doesn't yeah it's just the known
and so how was it playing with like was
that like the chip on your shoulder that
you play with or like you know what I'm
saying like because you didn't have no
any chances really going through the
minor leagues yeah yeah so that's shout
out to you like you bald and you had
this pressure on you
I didn't feel like I did at the time so
it's crazy to think about it now because
it's like that reality was real like you
didn't have much going if you had you
know slipped up or even yeah you was out
of there I was gone so
my thought process was just to dominate
the level I was at I pretty much knew I
wasn't gonna fly up whatever level I was
at I was probably gonna be there the
whole year
so and I knew I'd have that year to put
something together so that's kind of how
I approached it every single year
dial into what I could and this was
still switching yeah I was still
switching at the time so I was Finding
ways to put up some numbers and
just thinking about
how those years would go just every
single year was about the same I'd be
right around 250 going into the first
half or going into the second half and I
started lighting it up and then I look
up and I'm like
that's a good year yeah yeah it's a good
year and uh it was after low a so this
is 2016. low a I had the uh
manager come up to me and he said hey I
want you to shoot for double A next year
so completely skip Hyatt I was like what
and that's not yeah that's naughty I was
like man you crazy that makes sense for
our first second round guy yeah but not
for a 13th round yeah so when he said
that yep when he said that I knew I had
put up a year that was actually pretty
special maybe about
270 273 somewhere in there but I had
double digit Homer's triples and doubles
that year okay so I was like
okay so but I was so used to hitting
like 350 or something like that that
those numbers I was like are they sure
they should these are good yeah you're
just not used to that yeah so uh yeah
going going into the that spring
training
that was it that was the goal but the
crazy part about that spring training I
only had 13 of bets all this free
training going into 2017. what happened
I got I was getting called up to the big
league games every day oh so every day
yeah and what people don't know is
getting caught up to go to the big
league games
although you're in a big league game it
ain't you're not it's not what it it's
not fun really it's
okay so from my perspective it was like
because I'm going up here I'm sitting
eight Innings and I get to play three
outs yeah
maybe want it bad I don't get to go get
my four at bats and play my nine innings
and get in in shape like I want to but I
didn't have that thought yeah yeah I was
like I'm here with the squad it's like
uh
as soon as I get an opportunity shoot
I'm gonna be aggressive yeah I have
nothing to lose I mean I'm gonna be back
in the minors at some point you know but
during this time I'm going to treat it
as if I'm trying out for the team okay
yeah go from there but yeah and so
that's that's it that's it
hearing it that's a dope perspective
because I did not have that perspective
I was like man look I want to go over
there
and it's cool being around the guys but
I also want to be get your hundred
dollars
for the game yeah but I also want to go
take I'm trying to go hit back here you
know so that's that's that's dope that's
dope so go through the miners and then
we'll we'll get to the big lease part so
in 2020
you had
surgery
this is after the season after the
season you had surgery so uh
I don't want to talk about it I want you
to talk about yourself okay all right so
2020 was a crazy year uh spray training
normals always start off
uh I was dealing with
an infection my body that
they couldn't
name it basically couldn't tell me
exactly what was going on so I was on
antibiotics you know clear up and then a
week or two later it'll come back and
then coveted it and that's what set it
off so I'm in I was uh
at my wife's apartment in Virginia
trying to figure out what the heck is
going on with me and it's just me and
her but I'm on the phone with a bunch of
doctors and our team trainers and again
on antibiotics I was on antibiotics for
like three months on and off
and I finally
got a colonoscopy basically and he was
like yeah you have ulcers and fissures
and all kinds of craziness going on
in your uh
in your uh bow
and I was like okay so what's the next
step he's like well you you do have
Crohn's diseases anyone brought this up
to you before
I was like yeah it was it was brought to
my attention when I was like 18 but they
couldn't it wasn't a confirmed uh
diagnosis so I didn't take any
medication or anything for it and it
slowly just started to creep up it got
like infected or something and it
started to get infected so it was uh it
was laying on top of my bladder which
was infecting my bladder so that's why I
was like
really bad so I was like okay
so like yeah we're gonna we're gonna
need a surgery for this and I once they
said hey we're gonna have a season
I said I'll get back to you on that
surgery like I gotta I gotta I'm still
trying to make a name for myself just
trying to solidify so and they was cool
with you pushing it off they were cool
with it I mean they said it's not gonna
get much worse than where it's at right
now just got to maintain it manage it
and then
prepare for you right after so did it
slow anything like did it did it make
you feel so like were you did you get
more tired or
yeah it was a combination of stuff so
Chrome's basically inflammation in the
body that causes you to
you know have potential stomach cramps
um
you know throwing up stuff like that and
I wasn't really having those symptoms so
I said as long as I'm not
I'm gonna play through it okay
but uh they were saying that you know if
you had trouble gaining weight or
um
you know potential energy because your
iron levels kind of fluctuate
pretty heavily dealing with it and that
was one of the things I was doing with
just with randomly get tired I was like
but if I would eat some food prep it
back up I'd be good to go so went
through that season and then in November
had the surgery done
and it's how long was you down eight
weeks eight weeks so
I actually got
an infection from the surgery while I
was recovering so I had to go back to
the hospital I was going through it I
was going through it yeah yeah so I had
to go back to the hospital
and they ended up like
putting a drain in me to take out the
infection I had that drain with me for
two weeks I was just walking around
living everyday life with
basically a suction cup hanging out of
my body
[Laughter]
okay all right they didn't look good so
I was like okay
so and this is what this is what the
crazy part is leading up to 2021 I only
had a month that's what I was going to
ask you yeah that's literally because
all this time you're supposed to be
preparing for the next season yeah yeah
so
uh I think I started I think I did my
first workout January 14th
January 13th did you 14 did your first
workout and
you bought 2021 yeah
and
would you
was it like an extra motivation for you
throughout the season 100 what you just
went through 100 I knew I wasn't
switching anymore I said I got something
to prove there
I said I got just something to prove as
a as a baseball player in general
because like regardless of I was talking
to you know the the brass and I was like
I'm Gonna Be Ready for the season
I don't care how but I'm gonna be ready
because they're worried about obviously
me being or dating more time to you know
put some weight back on and but I put on
I lost roughly 20 pounds during that
whole process and I put back over 15 by
the time oh man the season was supposed
to stop or spray training yeah that's
great that's a lot of weight that's a
month
yeah 15 pounds yeah okay so then your
ball 2021 and this whole time or this
whole time have you always been a center
fielder
uh no I was uh I was you know playing
center field more more or less as a
replacement
um are you talking about like high
school and all that I mean big leagues
whenever you know yeah I've always been
a filter Okay so
who's your who who's your who would be
your favorite center fielder yeah Andrew
Jones Andrew Jones yes why Andrew Jones
that man did it all like just and me
being so young watching them and
understanding how good he was I had no
idea how good he was until I looked and
I was like I'm older now you know what
these numbers up oh my goodness stupid
unbelievable his number so so
obviously you're a very good Center for
yourself and you have social media tell
me about this AJ the AJ Rodriguez I'm a
kid because I've seen him on on my feed
yeah playing the show yeah and then yeah
you tell me about it okay so the fact
that I was able to talk to him finally
uh kind of verify the story so he's only
he plays the show he's a streamer and
he said that he had picked up one of my
cards I don't really know how it all
works I mean either so he picked up one
of my cars he was playing with me I
sucked with him okay he was like you
couldn't do it oh you were playing the
show no he was playing as well with me
on the show yeah and he was saying that
I was doing nothing for him
but every time he would face somebody
I'd go crazy that had me if they face
somebody that had me I'll go crazy for
like robbing a home run
exactly
and he'd get so mad because it was like
dude when I give you that opportunity on
my team you don't do nothing so
I just all of a sudden go online or go
on Twitter or whatever and I just see
him popping up it's Cedric wallets again
so I'm like where's the original video
and then I go and I feed I see that clip
of me robbing the home run all I can do
is laugh right all I can do is laugh
because when I finally met him he's like
bro you like jump started my career and
I was like shoot you kind of did the
same for me because it really just kind
of blew both of us up it just kind of
took off from there and no he's he's
cool for sure how did meeting him come
about like did you say you wanted to do
it or did you reach out to him yeah so
um it was just kind of kind of a natural
thing so the Angels came into town he
flew to come watch them play he's an
angels fan he's an angels fan yeah so he
flew over to come watch them play as
well it was a perfect opportunity so I
reached out to him said we got we got to
make this happen so he was all down for
it so he came to the game he did come to
the games yeah and you did he he came
down for BP or whatever you came down
from BP that's when I met to met him
talked to him uh and that night that's
kind of funny that night I hit up hit a
home run and they played that clip on
the jumbo Trail
I'm saying that he was in in town so I
was like that was that was a really fun
movie that's cool man that's that's
super dope for you uh to do something
like that because yeah you know that's
the Everlasting he'll always remember
some some stuff like that it was fun so
let me let me ask you about this bro
because one thing we do have in common
is the WBC
and
I've said it on the show already that
was the best baseball experience I've
ever had and I want to hear your
perspective on it because
no shade at all that's a tough lineup to
crack
yes and so you did not have the
opportunity to play every day so but you
did get to watch not just us but other
the other teams as well yeah and so how
was it from that perspective because I
only have the playing everyday
perspective I don't have the watching
perspective for the fans for me as well
that I want to know you know how was it
watching it just just getting asked to
be a part of that team was Martin
Lawrence oh wow okay when I got called
into the office
I was like yo I'm out of trouble like I
have no idea what's going on and they
were like yo we got a call
um are you interested in the WBC
at my I was like oh snap like that was
uh that was something I just wasn't
expecting
and I was like that yeah that's not it
was it was instant yeah like I said you
know it
where do I sign type situation so to
come in to be around you know UTA trial
all those guys that have been balling
and guys I've been watching for years
studying figuring out you know how are
they so consistent out there what are
they doing like I gotta pick their brand
gotta be around them that was my side of
it like being able to watch y'all's
process even in a game where
it's like in the back of your mind you
know he's like this is still kind of
spring training for me but once the
lights came on that I saw the intensity
like pick up real quick and of course
the crowd kind of did that you know just
the environment those games were crazy
those games were crazy crazy like I was
especially like we played Venezuela yeah
tell me so I want to hear that
perspective because playing it I felt a
certain way like playing it I was like
man this is this is a crazy game you
know but you're In the Heat of the
Moment Like You know I forgot that it
was even spring training you know I
forgot that I hadn't really had any of
bats yeah I'm in Grind Mode from the
beginning you know that kind of helped a
little bit you know getting through
spring training but you know tell me I
had the playing perspective of you just
kind of get lost in the game yeah but
watching it like how was it the how was
the feel like what was it because it was
a that was a dope baseball game yeah uh
watching it feels so much fun and at the
same time I'm like yo I could be used at
any moment yeah
I had to be prepared just in case this
is like shoot there might be a Pitch run
situation I might have to play some
defense so just
understanding that y'all I'm trying to
enjoy enjoy this experience like no
other and try to lock in and try to get
my work in this spring training schools
I'm like I still got to prepare for a
season as well
it was kind of weird kind of juggling
all that but I had the time of my life
like honestly I agree I I agree I think
yeah I for sure had the time in my life
so
when we when you went back to
camp
how was it for you like was it like kind
of boring not not not boring in a bad
way but like I just went from playing in
front of
I don't even know 30 40 000 and now I'm
playing in front of two thousand it
doled out real quick yeah so it was like
dang
yeah I could the season can start now
for me honestly that's how I felt
because we had I don't know how much
time about a week or so I think yeah
maybe maybe a week that week was long it
was a long week it was a long week and
and I was like you know I I was like you
know I studied a few more bets they were
asking me like do you feel behind I was
like honestly no no I don't it was like
because I was
picking everybody's brain getting an
idea just
trying to get an understanding of just
hitting a little more you know talking
to Griffey watching you and Griffey
communicate with each other I'm just in
the background I'm like you was always
around yeah but you always was quiet
yeah and you know I just didn't know I
peeped I peeped you but I just didn't
know like what what exactly were you
taking in info were you you know what
were you just chilling you know because
some people can just be a fly on the
wall and don't pay much yes no I was 100
my attention I was doing a bunch of
things I was
uh listen to y'all talk about just
baseball in general I was getting the
feel for personalities you know I'm a
bunch around and yeah around a bunch of
new people yeah so I've always been kind
of reserved in that department just kind
of looking around getting an idea of how
people go about their business and once
I kind of hit that Comfort level that's
when I was able to engage as well so it
was it was just uh just a process for me
and but at the end of the day it was it
was awesome do you feel like anything
that you learn from Griffey or any yeah
anything that you learned from Griffey
or Mikey or myself or Nolan or whoever
right do you feel like you've been able
to apply any any of that info now
yeah I'd say 100 I think that is
something that you took from Griffey or
somebody that you feel like you can
apply now just truly understanding
a full season
just uh the ups and downs how do you
handle them how do you approach
when you're not playing well to be able
to make one positive out of a day it's
like just just being able to watch that
I was able to see that and talk about
that and just again approaches on
certain pictures you know I'm I was
still kind of new to the left on left so
I was talking to every Lefty right every
Lefty tuck is probably I thought it took
about 20 30 minutes on the topic
chills ever he was like yeah this is
kind of what I do and so I was able to
kind of piece together certain things
incorporating my game in the mix
and she won't work
so that was something I for sure was
trying to get out of it and I mean heck
sure enough I got what got back spring
training first do what I see is a lefty
take him dead center oh yeah and I'm
like oh this stuff this stuff works so
I'm just trying to
trying to like really that was my
thought process like what can I get out
of this and it was that just understand
the process and understanding
how to go about certain situations and I
feel like like you said earlier the full
season understanding of full season like
the ups and the downs I think that gets
really overlooked the ups and the Downs
you know because people are hard on you
yeah and especially when you're in the
downs and it's hard it's hard to really
take because you want to play well for
not only just for you but for the team
because you know you know you got to
play well for the team to win yeah just
like adley hasn't played well all you
know uh Gunner has you know these uh
Mount Council guys had to play well and
so if they those important guys don't
play well
and the team loses
you know that you feel it yeah you feel
it and so but like I said going through
the ups and the Downs it's it's hard man
it's really hard on the mental it's so
hard on the mental man and you you could
get down so quick and because then time
starts to pass you by faster yeah it
does you forget what day it is and now
it's now it's August and what happened
in May you know and so it's hard to
remember and but what what is it what is
it something that you do to
because I I try and go and tenant bet in
increments okay I'll I'm doing 50. okay
50. I was doing 50. I used to do 100 and
then I said that's a lot that's a little
more than I can handle and it's hundreds
of too many hundreds are just too many
to go through a full month of especially
if you're not playing well to go to
through a full month and then assess
yourself that's way too much time I
think that's too much so 50 is roughly
that two week Mark and I was like I can
yeah I can do that for sure and you take
I take each day within those at bats and
I'm like okay days where I was able to
maybe draw a walk yep like that's huge
what was I what was I feeling that
moment like falling balls off okay I'm
found some balls off that means I'm
probably just missing maybe I'm a little
late you know I can address that but
swinging outside the Zone chasing and
just doing that every single time that
and then over the course of like I said
100 at bats
where do you start from there yeah
that's too much because then you're like
dang I got it let me start with swinging
a good pitches yep
that that takes a toll so but like you
said 10 10 at bats 20 at bats like I go
to 50.
it it definitely helps you process stuff
a little easier do you ever feel like
because a couple times there's a couple
times for me it's like all right let me
just start with just simply hitting the
ball
you know what I'm saying like sometimes
you break it all the way down that far
like just I gotta simply just hit the
ball right now I got to spend five at
bats to just hit the ball because right
now I'm not even making solid content do
you ever have to do things like that
yeah and and I try to and it gets really
frustrating when you have moments like
that for sure because I I rely on our
hitting coaches for sure yeah what do
you see
what am I not hitting if it's not the
fastball
like do I need to see spin do I need to
go in the cage to see spin do I need to
see some forces like
what do you see in my swing where I need
to see something different than what I
think I need
and that's kind of how I approach it
okay because I was never a huge fan of
machine for a long time and then I was
like it messes my timing I can't get my
my leg up in time this down the third
and now I rely on it to get me back yep
like maybe I need to shorten my swing up
okay put that thing below so I can go
it'll clean it up yeah yeah so you
figured out ways to do it okay so have
you have you heard of before we rap have
you heard of an Immaculate grid
yes I've been seeing that flying around
you've been seeing it around so I got
one for us oh God you want to do it with
me yeah yeah put it up please
I I just learned about what these were
really two days ago okay
so you you already know what it is I
don't have to explain the rules
I'm gonna go Houston and Texas I think I
know that one
um I know one at least I don't know you
know one Robinson Chirino says is the is
someone that comes in mind yes
um that I'm
100 100
sure he played yeah he did on both of
those chorinos with the CH yeah CH yeah
he he played on both
I'm Houston in Washington do you know
that one I think I know that one I I'm I
uh I think Jason worth but I'm not sure
if Jason worth was with Houston or not
worth w-e-r now I don't think that's how
you spell Jason
I think it's no Y in there
um
there it is yeah
I think Jason worth nope uh so I don't
know who was with Houston those are just
two in Washington yeah I don't know
Houston and Washington Houston in 200k
season has got to be guarantor yeah
gotta be careful that's for sure
um no maybe La in Washington is Jason
worth
he was with LA I I only known Worth to
be with Washington he may wasn't he
maybe I don't know I'm not sure
oh boy yes okay okay hello
so Seeger is definitely Texas in in LA
yes
of course here
go out in Texas I mean Kershaw has got
to be 200 cakes huh Kershaw for sure on
that one the yellow one gold glove for
Texas
the yeah he did I think yeah yeah
Kershaw for the last Kershaw
yeah there you go not the
the for the uh 200k for the 200k
okay all right so you said I said I
think Joey I think Joey Jello did want
to go go Joey gallo
hello there we go Washington with a gold
glow
huh
I gotta think the Victor Robles ever won
a gold
I don't I don't think he did you know I
don't think he's one of those
200 200ks that want to go up I'm gonna
go with Greg Maddox
geek
yeah
I'm thinking Greg Mattis yep right
Maddox okay so Washington and Gold Club
Rendon now did he ever want to go glow
Detroit no
Washington is such a hard one man oh I
don't even know all the people that
played with Washington
because it feels like they're always
circulating
yeah who has stuck with them long enough
for me to know they've won a gold gloves
oh man
I don't even know who played with
Houston Washington well this is do you
think uh do you think Zimmerman ever won
a first base
Brian Zimmerman yeah
yeah he'd been there forever he's a
solid first baseman all right
try and see
oh
can we get can we get to see who the top
one is
is that is I don't know how Immaculate
grids work
can we is there a way to see who could
have been it may not be I don't know
Will Harris he
he's a teacher he was the right-handed I
know you're talking about Will Harris
yes well anyways we came close we got
close it was solid
um but anyways Sid thanks for coming on
the show bro you know this is uh it's
been cool but before we rap all the way
we got a couple fan questions okay I
ain't trying to I ain't trying to kick
you off the show like that all right all
right like that so say are you
ambidextrous in other sports
um daily activities or are you just like
switch hitting like does switch hitting
mean that you're ambidextrous I don't
even know what that I guess that's not
the question that's that's kind of how I
got introduced to it because I do
everything
like
I guess daily activities wise eating
brushing your teeth I do have my right
hand but Sports I do everything with my
left I cook I kick with my left I throw
up my left I was I naturally hit on my
left
but everything else I did with my right
so which hand is stronger for you like
if you were to just I gotta punch
somebody which it would be the left it
would be the left
so you're really my arm wrestle I might
go am I right oh so you weird okay yeah
cool all right so what do you think uh
another question is what do you think
about the Oriole city connect Jersey
I actually like them so when they hem
them up to show the color around the uh
the collar
I like that more because I said you know
I didn't understand the hidingly color
aspect of it for the for I guess for
promotional purposes right you want
people to understand why hide
so I like that we were able to show a
little more color on that
um
the overall uniform is solid I like some
of the cleats that you guys have for
them like those really nice I said okay
that Pairs and you can wear any color
right any color there's so many there's
so many boxes of different colors if I
wanted a blue arm guard with a purple
sleeve and pink cleats
it will still work is that what you is
that what you wear is that what we
expecting I wore I wore a purple sleeve
shout out to the Ravens I wore you got
it from Lamar Johnson Lamar I wore uh
orange tape
Flex tape and cleats you know whatever
whatever Uh custom house ones I had
which typically be the like the orange
ones that fade in the white
so I like those with it and uh so yeah
it's a clean look nice okay so I got one
more question
would you rather be invisible for a day
or be able to fly for one day
yeah I'll probably go with flying fly
yeah I'm gonna go invisible I'm
invisible I would go invisible see
I don't know what you'd be doing right
that's the whole day and I'm gonna let
you let you be on that end
yeah flying flying really would be dope
even if it was anywhere everywhere fast
gotta go to the store fly I'm gonna take
off
see being invisible at the story just
gonna see but being invisible at the
store I'm just gonna walk in there and
I'm gonna steal everything you know what
I'm saying they're gonna see they may
see they're gonna see the floating items
they don't see the cart pushing itself
straight out there I don't know we'll
see maybe I can make that in business
you might have to try it out I will see
but anyways
said thanks for coming on the show man
um you know it's super dope I'm glad
we got another brother being successful
in the league handling things the right
way doing things the right way leading
guys the right way so uh I wish much
continued success for you and for those
out there this is said Mullins if you
look up
it's not a bird it's not a plane it's
said Mullins flying to Oriole Park
see you guys later on
foreign
[Music]